now former las vegas raider henry ruggs
is in a clark county jail this morning
that's right he is accused by metro
police of killing a woman while driving
under the influence in that crash late
last night rugs was released by the las
vegas raiders and in a few hours the 22
year old faces a judge for the first
time hector mcchia joining us live now
with the latest on those charges hector
we've learned ruggs has been booked into
the clark county detention center facing
two felony charges dui resulting in
death and reckless driving resulting in
death it all happened right here at the
center section yesterday right around 3
30 this morning and today we have
candles a makeshift memorial for the
victim police say she was only 23 years
old killed here at the intersection at
rainbow and spring valley parkway
investigators say she was trapped in her
toyota rav4 it burst into flames
metro police say henry ruggs was driving
the corvette that rear ended that toyota
both were northbound on rainbow rugs
accused of driving at a high rate of
speed when he veered into the right lane
and crashed neighbors are left stunned
this crash took a human life
i wanted to go out there and i want to
pray for the person i feel like that was
the least i can do like pray for them
for their soul
the many were sound asleep when they
were woken up by the loud sounds of that
crash investigators say ruggs stayed on
the scene showed signs of impairment he
was treated for non-life-threatening
injuries and he is being held without
bail his first court appearance this
morning is scheduled at nine o'clock
we'll of course be there and bring you
the latest reporting live hector mejia
live local now all right